my love for reading came from another
one of my tweets is read what you love
until you love to read so just fall in
love with the idea of reading itself so
it's okay to read the junk food stuff
just fall in love with reading and
eventually get bored of the simple stuff
and you'll go to the more interesting
stuff and i love to read enough that i
don't like watching tv i don't watch
movies you know people start talking
about shows that they're watching on
netflix or what have you and i give them
this empty look i don't watch shows on
netflix they're not interesting it's far
more interesting to me to go for a walk
and be meditative and i'll be in a very
happy place or to read a book which will
be intellectually stimulating and sure
once in a while watch a movie with
friends or with my wife
but it's a social thing you know i'm
doing it as a way of kind of sort of
being on the same common ground as them
i'm not i would never watch a movie on
my own unless maybe i was trapped in
like a 15-hour airplane flight and i was
really bored and i run out of everything
else to do and i just want to zone out
even then i don't think i watch a movie
anymore